even heroes make terrible mistakes from
time to time
in fact some movies they're hardly
heroes at all with that in mind here's a
look at some of the more glaring good
guy misfires in movie history there's
one thing you have to give to Daniel
Hillard he loves his kids I need to be
with my children I'll do anything
unfortunately that didn't make him a
good husband and when his marriage broke
up the out-of-work actor lost custody of
his children until he could get steady
work and the place to live it's a little
harsh but also job and home are a couple
of pretty low bars to clear as someone
who's supposed to be raising three
children and yet when Daniels life
inevitably crumbles around him he
decides that it's a better idea to
create a false identity to his ex-wife
into hiring him as a nanny to his own
children and then tried to sabotage a
new relationship whether or not you buy
into mrs. Doubtfire heartwarming charm
that is straight-up sociopathic behavior
at best he's a liar and the worst
dragging your children into a
complicated web of lies and deception is
the sort of thing that's going to
require years of therapy before they can
even begin to trust again Daniel has
decent enough goals but he betrays the
trust of his entire family and
unquestionably proves that his ex-wife
was right about everything it's easy to
forget that in 2002 s horror classic the
ring Rachel Keller was a journalist
chasing a lead tied to the suspicious
death of her niece it's that misguided
search for the juicy story that leads
her to samaras deadly tape and hits her
tragic misunderstanding of the situation
that leads her to help with the accursed
child needless to say that was a bad
idea not only does she unleash Samara
spirits and cause yet another death she
also makes multiple copies of the tape
again she's got the noble goal of saving
her son but with two tapes out there
she's also condemning unknown numbers of
people to die in the future and the
worst part she didn't even get to file
her story if you've seen Avengers age of
Ultron you already know that Bruce
Banner and Tony Stark's attempt at
creating a helpful artificial
intelligence wound up going bad in an
act of astonishing hubris these two
geniuses put their new creation in
charge of Tony's gadget Factory and
shield itself and then went to a party
without bothering to check and see if
anything had gone wrong the result was
Ultron a killer robot who destroyed
sokovia and what was in doubtedly the
Marvel
nematic universe's most devastating act
of destruction
at least until Thanos showed up while
bana responded to the incident by flying
off to space and spending two years as a
big green gladiator hey was actually
cheaper than therapy totally just kept
making things worse his guilt over
sokovia led to the Registration Act that
prompted a civil war with Captain
America which in turn left Earth's
heroes divided when Thanos arrived with
the Infinity stones Tony's still out
there trying to fix things but given his
track record over the past few years
maybe he should just focus on making a
new phone Star Wars fans the world over
would have you believe that obi-wan
Kenobi is one of the wisest characters
on a galaxy far far away but let's be
honest with each other
obi-wan pretty much messes up everything
all the time in Star Wars Episode one
The Phantom Menace young obi-wan almost
single-handedly destroys the Jedi when
he demands against a better judgment of
Yoda and pretty much every member of the
Jedi Council to train Anakin Skywalker
spoiler warning but that didn't work out
so well for him or any of the younglings
at Jedi school all the people of
Alderaan or well you get the idea
jump ahead to a new hope and you'll see
obi-wan doesn't really fare much better
by keeping the identity of Luke
Skywalker's father a secret if nothing
else knowing his full story from the
start of things could have saved him
from passionately kissing his own sister
Grandpa Joe is unquestionably set up as
chardee buckets personal hero in 1971's
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
he's the first person shaadi runs to
after winning the contest and is also
Charlie's plus-one on their fateful tour
of the unhinged candy tycoons confection
Factory before we get into that
psychedelic tour though let's revisit
the fact that Grandpa Joe is bedridden
when the film begins he even claims to
be incapable of working thus leaving his
family to live in utter poverty and so
Charlie comes charging through the door
with a ticket to unlimited chocolate the
second that happens chrome Pardo is
suddenly and suspiciously capable of
dancing around the one-room hovel where
he's been living rent-free for who knows
how long on the tour it's Joe who
encourages Charlie to steal some of the
fizzy lifting drink which nearly leads
them both to being diced up by the fan
in the ceiling vents and almost
disqualifies Charlie from inheriting
Wonka's factory it's always nice to
spend time with you
parents but maybe Charlie would be
better off not hanging out with a
geriatric sub-domain e AK con man on
paper Scott pilgrims tale is in fact a
romantic epic full of 8-bit Flair Edgar
Wright stylish blend of action comedy
and romance makes Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world are one-of-a-kind cinematic
experience so much so that it's easy to
forget that Scott himself is a bit of a
scumbag sure it's a bummer that is
forced to fight and defeat all eight of
Ramona Flowers evil exes in order to
prove his love but let's not forget that
the 20-somethings Scott was dating naive
high schooler knives ciao the whole time
he was pursuing Ramona though Scott
atones for his actions late in the film
he never really does right by knives
ultimately leaving her brokenhearted and
treading water in his oh so romantic
self-serving wake in Shaun of the Dead
Simon Pegg might just be playing the
ultimate slacker hero he works at a
low-level electronics store he can't
remember his mother's birthday he hangs
out with his we dealing besties way too
much and he can't seem to commit to his
longtime girlfriend Liz when the dead
walking threatened to end humanity Shawn
finally steps up and sets out to save
the lives of everyone he loves by taking
them to his favorite pub and having a
drink while things blow over they
drinking during the apocalypse might
sound like a good idea but in Shawn's
case it's an absolute disaster even
setting aside that perilous road to get
to the Winchester matters get out of
hand quickly when Shawn and his crew
find their way inside and people start
to die not Shawn though he somehow finds
a way to safety and even manages to save
less still Shawn will be forced to live
the rest of his life with the blood of
those fallen companions on his hands
giving a whole new meaning to the phrase
you've got red on you here's a few
pointers for all of the lovers out there
who can't quite tell whether or not that
certain someone you've just met is the
one if you wake up in the middle of the
night and find them in your room
uninvited and watching you sleep it's
time to end that relationship if they
break up with you in the middle of the
woods and leave you there crying and
alone rather than giving you a ride home
you should stay broken up if they're
overprotective to the point of
threatening your friends just because
they're talking to you you might want to
take some space if they ever almost kill
you because they really really like the
taste of your blood you should probably
seek out the authorities and for pete's
sake if they turn to you after just a
few days and declare you are my life now
just go ahead and get us
draining order since Twilight hit
theaters in 2008 some of Edward Cullen's
sparkly sheen has lost its luster and
people are starting to see that he was
really just an undead creep and that
Bella's life would have been totally
fine if he had just left her alone
being a superhero means making enemies
and making enemies means the people you
love will always be in peril that's the
one lesson Peter Parker learns the hard
way and the amazing spider-man tear and
he learns it at the expense of his
girlfriend Gwen Stacy of course Peter
didn't have to learn that lesson at all
because he had someone explicitly lay
out the stakes of being a hero
Gwen's father police captain George
Stacy died while saving spider-man's
life with his dying words he had one
simple request but pizza not date his
daughter so she'd never be the target of
one of spider-man's enemies a last pizza
completely ignores it in the sequel so
it should come as no surprise that Gwen
is eventually taken hostage by the bad
guys and pays for Peters heroics with
her life if only someone had warned him
this exact thing would happen Oh Wayne